we are living through a historic turning
point in American politics for 50 years
this country was run by an establishment
policy gender shared by both parties in
favor of globalization automation
uncontrolled immigration and the
centralization of government and the
economy in 2016 that consensus was
overthrown in a populist revolution of
course Donald Trump on the right but
also Bernie Sanders paving the way for
what we see today the Democrats lurch to
the populist left that is dangerous for
America
because the more we see of these new
loony left policies the clearer it is
that they'd bring disaster for our
economy and society but it's a danger
for Republicans too because unless they
develop a positive populist agenda of
their own they'll just be swept away
that's because on issue after issue the
populist left is responding to people's
real concerns Americans are right to be
angry about inequality if you're part of
the globally connected knowledge economy
elite your wealth has soared over the
last few decades but for most working
Americans incomes have been flat or
falling since the 1970s worse many
millions of responsible Americans who
work hard still find themselves in a
permanent and precarious state of
economic insecurity for example a recent
federal reserve study found that 40% of
Americans couldn't afford a $400
emergency expense like an unexpected
medical bill in response a o'seas green
new deal now backed by most leading
Democrat presidential candidates
promises high paying federal jobs to
anyone who wants one Cory Booker has
actually introduced a job guarantee bill
claiming it would give all Americans a
shot at a day's work and by introducing
competition into the labor market raise
wages and improved benefits for all
workers but the paper that his plan drew
from estimated the total annual cost of
a federal jobs guarantee to be over five
hundred billion dollars it's obvious who
dendup paying for it the taxpayer which
of course is all part of the plan for
the loonie left populist once you get to
like the tippy
tops on your ten millionth dollar
sometimes you see tax rates as high as
60 or 70% tippy tops get enough of that
all right presidential candidate who
Leon Castro also wants to revoke the
Trump tax cuts
I absolutely would look at undoing the
the tax cuts that benefited the super
wealthy and benefited corporations wake
up whoo Leon I think you're not gonna
get the presidency if you're half asleep
when you do your interviews anyway
Elizabeth Warren she's planning a new
wealth tax quote we need structural
change she says that's why I'm proposing
an annual tax on the wealth of the
richest Americans but these taxes are
not structural change they're punitive
not positive high taxes would actually
hurt working Americans by cutting
investment leading to lower growth and
fewer jobs wealth taxes make the rich
poorer they don't make the poor richer
but here's the key political point
Republicans can't just scream Venezuela
about all this loony leftism you need a
positive populist alternative to give
working Americans Economic Security so
instead of higher taxes on the rich
how about lower taxes on workers slash
payroll taxes and institute a real
living wage it doesn't make any sense
that the federal minimum wage hasn't
budged in almost 10 years when the cost
of living has only continued to rise but
in a broader sense
what the left's version of populism gets
wrong about inequality and poverty is
the superficial way they approach it
their plans target the symptoms of
poverty we should be aiming at the
underlying causes and one of the biggest
is family breakdown census data shows
that children living with a divorced
single parent are 50% more likely to be
living below the poverty line compared
to children from two-parent homes
another study showed that quote the
fraction of children living in
single-parent households is the
strongest negative correlate of upward
income mobility the left lecture us all
the time about believing the science on
climate change well it's time they
stopped denying the science on Family a
child starts life at a steep
disadvantage if they come from a broken
family
the neighborhood they live in the
schools they attend even the food they
these are all factors that impact
childhood development are affected by
household income which plunges if a
family breaks up or never gets together
in the first place here's what the
populist Left gets wrong about
inequality Americans understand that
inequality is the price you pay for
opportunity and they're prepared to pay
that price as long as everyone has
access to opportunity
but the reason Americans are so angry
right now is that the ladder of
opportunity has been broken conservative
populist need to put the wrongs back on
that ladder to reboot social mobility
that means helping families come
together and stay together but of course
it also means fixing education in too
many parts of the country our schools of
blocking opportunity instead of building
it 2016 figures show that in 1/3 of
Baltimore's public high schools not a
single student scored proficient on the
state's math exam not a single one
another study found that in Chicago one
in four African American students
attends a subpar school of course there
are many excellent public schools in
America but they're typically the one
serving neighborhoods where families are
already doing well
a Stanford study found that the gap in
standardized test scores between
affluent and low-income students has
grown by about 40 percent between 1960
and 2007 the proven answer to this is to
help children escape failing schools by
giving their parents real choice of
course the public sector unions hate
that because it's a threat to their
power but instead of backing opportunity
they're loony left populist back the
unions who block it Kamala Harris
Elizabeth Warren they're all falling
over themselves to suck up to their big
Union donors what a bunch of hypocrites
they are railing against the rich then
doubling down on a very system that
perpetuates inequality in America the
public sector education monopolies
radical school choice should be the next
big crusade for conservative populist
and is one that has the advantage of
being truly popular with 73 percent
support among Latinos 68 percent among
whites and nearly the same with
african-americans but our education
system blocks
opportunity beyond high school and once
again left-wing populist have exactly
the wrong answer we should have free
tuition at public colleges and
universities that should be a right of
all Americans no I think the word you're
looking for bernie is wrong it's wrong
to force every young American at
taxpayer expense into a cookie cutter
four-year college program ending in a
useless degree that won't lead to a job
but will land them with crippling debt
the unemployment rate for 16 to 24 year
olds is over twice the national average
and student loan borrowers owe close to
1.5 trillion dollars but the left-wing
populist strike accord when they focus
on this issue so conservative populist
need a positive answer it's time for a
radical rethink of the whole system make
it much more open and flexible help
students focus on their individual
strengths often that might be a blue
collar career quote the jobs that make
civilized life possible as my guest Mike
Rowe put it a few weeks ago give every
American the opportunity to thrive in
the economy of the future with ongoing
affordable access to skills training
from the private sector build on the
great start made by Ivanka Trump and her
National Council for the American worker
on jobs on schools on family we've seen
a decades-long collapse in opportunity
yes things have started to turn around
and that's great but a half century of
establishment rule brought deep problems
for working Americans and the appeal of
socialism is no surprise when capitalism
failed for so many that's why is a huge
risk for Republicans to just sit back
and hope the loonie left populist simply
self-destruct the establishment it's
dead America is not going back to the
corrupt and incompetent never Trampas
and their swampy counterparts in the
Democratic Party
the future is populist the question is
what kind the negative vindictive
top-down centralizing authoritarianism
of the left or a positive people power
version of populism on the right Pro
worker pro-family Pro community tell me
what you think of that that Steve Hill
eggs and at next Rev FNC soon we'll take
a look at the populous choice on
immigration health care and much more